Guten Tag.
Ich bin Dr. Seifetin Östensoy. Ich bin der Dienstabendarzt in dieser Stelle.
Und heute werde ich das Annemnesgespräch bei Ihnen mit Ihnen durchführen. Sind Sie damit einfach standen?
Ja.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Natalie Schmidt.
Natalie Schmidt.
Schmidt mit DT oder D?
Mit DT.
DT.
Natalie, am Ende gibt es eine E oder?
Mit IE.
Mit IE. Dankeschön.
Wie alt sind Sie Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 35 Jahre alt.
30 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genehmigt geboren? Könnten Sie mir bescheid geben?
Ich bin am 15. September 1989 geboren.
Entschuldigen Sie, ich konnte nichts veröschten. Könnten Sie mich wieder einigen?
Am 15. September 1989.
Dankeschön.
Wie groß sind Sie Frau Schmidt?
Ich bin 1,70 m groß.
Wie viele wiegen Sie?
60 Kilogramm.
Und wie heißt Ihre Hausarztin oder Hausarzt?
Das ist Frau Paul.
Frau Paul.
Und wann sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Büro als Spirationskauffrau.
Spirationskauffrau.
Was ist Ihre Hautbeschwer der Frau Schmidt?
Könnten Sie mir auch ein bisschen mehr überlegen?
Ich bin ein Spirationskauffrau.
Was ist Ihre Hautbeschwer der Frau Schmidt?
Könnten Sie mir in ein paar Sätze beschreiben?
Ja, ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich wieder Bauchschmerzen habe,
wieder Blähungen habe und wieder Durchfall habe.
Bauchschmerzen, Blähungen und Durchfall.
Ja.
Und ich habe jetzt seit kurzem eine extreme Müdigkeit.
Okay, dann.
Wann sind Ihre Beschwerden angefangen?
Das habe ich schon länger, aber das wird jetzt immer lästiger und immer mehr.
Okay, die sind fermartig in diesem Fall.
Ja, ich habe das schon seit langem diese Beschwerden.
Okay, dann.
Könnten Sie Ihre Bauchschmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Ist das krampfartig?
Ja, das ist sehr langartig.
Ja, genauer beschreiben ist das krampfartig, tunf oder...
Es ist eher so krampfartig, aber auch drückend.
Krampfartig und rückend.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Lokalisation für dieses Schmerzen?
Nein, eigentlich der gesamte Bauchraum.
Gesamt.
Gibt es eine bestimmte Ausdöser oder Verlinderter Faktor?
Ein Was?
Haben Sie bemerklichst ein Ausdöser oder Trigger für dieses Schmerzen?
Hab ich nicht selber bemerkt, nein.
Ist Ihre Schmerzen auch ein Gehäuse von Leigerung oder eine bestimmte Körperposition?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, nein.
Könnten Sie einschätzen Ihre Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzskala von 1 bis 10?
Wobei 1 ist leichtes Schmerzen und 10 ist das stärkste Schmerzen.
Ja, so 6 würde ich sagen.
6, ja.
Gibt es keine Ausdöser oder Verlinderter Faktor?
Und gibt es irgendwohin eine Ausstrahlung von diesem Schmerzen?
Nein, der gesamte Bauchraum.
Sie haben mir gesagt, Sie haben die Jahre auf, Durchfall auf.
Könnten Sie mir beschreiben Ihre Stuhlgang?
Ist das sehr, sehr mäßig und vielmehr am Tag?
Also ich habe eher so Durchfall.
Und ich gehe so ungefähr 2-3 Mal am Tag, gehe ich schon auf Toilette.
Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass es mehr wird.
Haben Sie eine bestimmte Patroliestression auf Ihrem Stuhl?
Zum Beispiel ein Blut oder Schleim?
Gibt es ein Patroliest?
Eine was?
Aus einem Normal, ich beschreibe.
Bitte?
Könnten Sie mir sagen, haben Sie etwas gesehen auf Ihrem Stuhl?
Zum Beispiel Blut, Schleim oder irgendwelche?
Hab ich nicht gesehen, nein.
Das ist ganz normal.
Wie ist die Diskostate oder Form?
Diskos was?
Form, wie ist Ihre Stuhlform?
Durchfall?
Ja, genau.
Durchfall ist eine Stuhl?
Nein, ich wollte Ihre Stuhl beschreiben.
Wie ist Ihre Form?
Ist das flüssig?
Ja, flüssig.
Was ist das Problem bei Maseralsen?
Nein.
Sie haben auch Medikate.
Wie äußert Sie diese Medikate?
Während einer Belastung?
Auch, aber auch in Ruhe.
Ich bin weniger antriebslos.
Ich habe meinen Haushalt kaum noch.
Ich schleppe mich zur Arbeit.
Ich habe mich nicht gut konzentriert.
Auch wenn die Bauchschmerzen auf der Arbeit sind.
Ich habe mich jetzt schon mehrfach krankschreiben lassen.
Weil ich nicht arbeiten konnte wegen den Bauchschmerzen.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ihre Lust verloren?
Auf die Dinge, die Sie machen?
Regalmäßig oder als Hobby?
Ich habe mich nicht mehr verstanden.
Aber ich habe keine Kraft.
Haben Sie Atemnoten?
Nein.
Aber ich bin sehr schnell müde.
Wenn ich jetzt einkaufen gehe,
oder Treppen steige, muss ich mich ausruhen.
Haben Sie Herzprobleme?
Herzrhythmusstörungen?
Herzglappern?
Gibt es irgendwelche Veränderungen auf Ihrem Haut?
Nein.
Brockenhaut oder nasschenhaut?
Haben Sie bemerkt irgendwelche Veränderungen in Ihrem Augen?
Nein.
Sie haben Durfweil und haben Sie Naziweiß?
Stellfrust?
Nein.
Ich habe ein wenig Veränderung.
Ich habe ungefähr 4-5 kg verloren.
Wie lange war es?
halbis Jahr.
Es war eine Umgewendung?
Ja, eine Entschuldigung.
Umgewandelt oder nicht?
Nein, ich würde gerne etwas zunehmen,
als ich bin.
Ich kriege 60 kg und bin 71 kg groß, also ich würde noch gerne ein bisschen zunehmen.
Aber ich war halt 65 kg vorher.
Also von daher, ich will gar nicht abnehmen.
Das ist so ungewollt, okay, in diesem Punkt.
Und haben Sie stapfig Turngern?
Nein.
Gibt es irgendwelche Verantwortungen im Appetit?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Sie haben keinen Herzsturgen oder Herzsturben auf keinen Atemnot.
Sie haben vorher mehr gesagt.
Und außer, dass Sie etwas hinzufügen möchten,
als Begleitzentrum oder andere wichtige Informationen, die ich nicht fragte.
Das ist dann wichtig.
Zum Beispiel abhängen von Ihrem Krankheit oder Ihrem Stress schon.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich habe.
Okay, ihr habt jetzt irgendwie etwas andere Begleitzentrum.
Entschuldigend.
Begleitzentrum?
Ja, genau, Begleitzentrum.
Ich weiß nicht, was Sie meinen.
Hast du Bauchschmerzen?
Ich meine, Sie haben Bauchschmerzen, außer dem haben Sie Fieber
oder Wichtige.
Wie war ich denn?
Ich mag mir schon Sorgen, weil ich jetzt auch so viel abgenommen habe.
Und der Durchfall einfach nicht aufhört.
Ich habe seit langem keinen normalen Stuhlgang mehr.
Ich weiß nicht, dass es ein wichtiges Restaurant ist.
Also ein schwieriges Restaurant.
Nachdem wir uns befunden und nach dem Körper aufhören,
werden wir darüber besser und deutlich sprechen.
Ich denke, wir werden eine bestimmte Lösung finden zu Ihrem Stress.
Jetzt komme ich Ihre Vorerkrankungen.
Haben Sie chronische Vorerkrankungen?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Ich nehme gar nichts an.
Ich möchte doch keine Medikamente einnehmen.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie Allergie?
Nein.
Haben Sie Voropressionen?
Nein, ich habe eine Polypomoperation.
Sind Sie Alkohol?
Nein.
Nehmen Sie diese Frage nicht persönlich,
aber das ist eine Luttermeske Frage.
Wenn Sie diese Frage stellen, haben Sie irgendwelche Kontaktmitdrogen?
Noch nie gehabt.
Okay, rufen Sie Frau Schmidt?
Nein.
Könnten Sie mir sagen, Ihre Akten sind am Leben?
Ja.
Dann haben Sie irgendwelche chronische Erkrankungen,
Ihre Vater oder Mutter?
Mein Vater hat Herzprobleme.
Er hat, glaube ich, Bluthochdruck.
Und ich glaube, der hält Cholesterinwerte.
Meine Mutter ist depressive, hat eine Depression.
Seit wann hat Ihre Mutter diese Depression-Stration behandelt?
Schon mehr.
Ja, sie wird behandelt.
Sie war auch schon mal kranker ausgewiesen.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich bin Einzelkind.
Sie arbeiten als Spender in der Verkauferin.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Leben Sie allein oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Ich lebe mit einer Freundin zusammen.
Haben Sie Probleme oder Stress beim Arzt?
Arbeit, bei der Arbeit.
Geht, nochmal.
Es ist jetzt nicht sehr ausgeprägt.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Ihre Stimmung verändert
oder haben Sie das bemerkt?
Was verändert?
Stimmung.
Ihre Laune oder?
Ja, irgendwie werde ich losloser.
Aber ich würde gerne, aber ich kriege es irgendwie nicht hin.
Meine Freundin, mit der ich zusammen die Wohnung teile,
sagt auch, dass ich ab und zu mal laut werde, aggressiv werde.
Aber auch manchmal wein ich auch.
Das kommt auch vor.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Hobbys?
Ich lese und ich male.
Nein, ich male.
Könnten Sie konzentrieren in der letzten Zeit im Lesen und male?
Oder wollen Sie nichts mehr machen?
Konzentrieren kann?
Ja, konzentrieren oder seit Verbringung mit diesem Modest.
Das ist gut, aber ich habe jetzt lange nicht mehr gemalt,
weil ich einfach keine Lust mehr so richtig habe.
Frau Schmidt, sind Sie geimpft?
Ich bin voll geimpft, sagt mir mein Haushaltsmeer.
Hab mir mein Haushaltsbestätigt.
Dann haben Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland waren Sie?
Ich war nur in Holland.
Wann waren Sie dort?
Im August war ich da.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Reisen?
Zum Beispiel eine Krankheit?
Hat dich auch durchfallen.
Frau Schmidt, Sie haben alle benötigte und wichtige Informationen
von Ihnen bekommen.
Wollen Sie etwas in Zufugchen?
Haben Sie irgendetwas schrieben?
Ja, können Sie mir helfen?
Können Sie mir sagen, was ich habe,
dass ich das schon so lange mit mir trage
und dass ich keine Lösung dafür finde?
Ja, genau, wir werden unbedingt eine Lösung finden.
Aber erst brauchen wir ein paar Seiten
und ein paar Untersuchungen.
Auch ein paar Labortesten.
Wir informieren Ihre Stression.
Auch Ihre Stression muss ich mit meinem Oberarzt bewerten
und urteilen, was das Problem ist.
Danach werden wir bestimmte Diagnose stellen.
Vermutet sich schon irgendetwas?
Kann das etwas Gefährliches sein?
Zurzeit kann ich nachher
deutliche Informationen geben.
Aber nach dem Untersuchungen gehen wir auf und befinden.
Wir werden eine bessere Konversation durchführen.
Ich denke.
Ich würde schon gehen,
dass Sie mich heute stationär aufnehmen.
Ich möchte wissen, was ich habe.
Dass Sie alles untersuchen,
weil ich keinen Lust mehr.
Ich möchte Sie komplett untersuchen.
Ich habe das Leben noch vor mir.
Ich möchte nicht so sein, wie ich jetzt bin.
Das ist eine wichtige Stression.
Das verändert Ihre
prägliche Stression und auch die Lebensstück.
Deswegen müssen wir eine Lösung finden.
Bitte keine Sorge.
Danke schön.
Ich fühle, dass Sie eine Möglichkeit haben.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Sie haben erwähnt,
dass Sie seit so lange diese Beschwerden haben.
Waren Sie schon beim Arzt?
Ich war beim Haushalt.
Ich habe eine Rolle gemacht.
Aber der hat nichts gefunden.
Er hat mich nicht gefühlt.
Ich habe mich nicht gefühlt.
Ich habe gar nichts gefunden.
Er hat mich krankgeschrieben.
Er hat mich über den 갑ut als Schall gemacht.
Er hat gesagt, er hat nichts gemacht.
Wurden Sie eine Koloskopie gefühlt?
Nein, er hat gesagt, er würde zu jung dafür werden.
Ich war sogar mehrmals bei ihm.
Er hat gesagt, es geht nicht gut.
Er ermöglicht mich.
Es geht nicht weg.
Die sind 35 Jahre alt.
Wann treten die Beschwerden auf?
Schon lange, bestimmt schon seit,
das hat bestimmt schon ein Jahr, vielleicht 10 Monats, ein Jahr.
Seitdem habe ich das schon.
Haben Sie vermehrt Schwitzen oder vermehrt Intoleranz?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Sind Ihre Regelbildungen regelmäßig?
Ja, eigentlich schon.
Ich möchte noch ein paar Fragen.
Wie ernähren Sie sich?
Essen Sie für Brot?
Ich versuche mich gesund zu ernähren.
Wegen Vegetarien und so weiter.
Wegen Vegetarien.
Ich esse alles.
Ich esse kaufen gutes Brot.
Ich esse auch Kohlenhydrat.
Ich esse auch Eiweiße.
Ich esse auch Fleisch, viel Salat.
Ich versuche mich ausreichend und bewusst zu ernähren.
Haben Sie das bemerkt,
dass Ihre Beschwerden nach dem Brot essen,
im Vermert, oder?
Ich habe mich nicht darauf geachtet.
Eine Frage?
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie schon einmal Gelenkschmerzen oder Schwellung
oder Augenentzündung gehabt?
Augenentzündung nicht,
aber ich habe manchmal selten Gelenkschmerzen.
Aber selten, das stört mich nicht so.
Ich male, ja, und wenn ich male,
habe ich gedacht, das ist deswegen.
Ich schmerzen,
aber da versectet die Schwierger.
Die Schmerzen kommen und gehen.
Die Schmerzen werden wenn sie verändernd werden.
Überall, am ganzen Bauchum.
Okay.
Nein, das ist nichts, die Sie haben gefragt.
Bitte.
Nein, das ist nichts.
Er hat keine Frage, ob ich werde, nach dem Essen oder so.
Nach dem Essen rachunzi, rachunzi Patiente.
Rachunzi Patiente? Nein, nein.
Ich denke alle Fragen ist takt, ich denke.
Können wir als erstes küschen, wenn man fangen kann?
Und mir aus? Ja.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patiente.
Ich möchte Sie an Ihnen vorstellen, haben Sie Zeit?
Ja.
Es geht um Natalya Schmidt.
Sie ist 35-jährige Patientin.
Sie ist 1,70 Meter groß.
1,70 Meter.
Entschuldigung, 1,70 Meter.
Okay, ich schuldige Sie, 1,70 m groß und 60 kg schwer.
Sie ist eine Spätendürverkauferin.
Sie klagte heute über eine Bauchmerzen.
Sie hat Diöre und Müdigkeit.
Die Schmerzen sind kraftartig und durchkennend.
Seit langer Zeit bestehen die Schmerzen.
Die Schmerzen lokalisieren im ganzen Bauch bereit.
Es gibt keine bestimmte Lokalisation.
Ich schuldige Sie, dass es keine Ausstrahlung gibt.
Auf einer Skala berichtete Sie die Schmerzen 6 von 10.
Es gibt keine bestimmte Symptome,
sondern es gibt eine Stimmung bis auf die Diöre.
Sie hat 2-3 Mal täglich eine Stimmung.
Sie sieht normal aus.
Aber der Stur ist fräßig.
Hojam, können Sie die Vorstellung zusammenfassen?
Mit 35-jährigen Patienten, die seit einem Jahr
an bestehenden Bauchschmerzen
mit Diöre bis zu 3 Mal ein Tag leidet,
ohne Blutbeimengungen, ohne Erbrechen, ohne Übelkeit.
Die Stimmung wird verneint.
Sie haben 5-7 kg im letzten Jahr.
Sie haben eine Erkrankung.
Sie nehmen keine Medikamente ein.
Sie sind nicht allergisch.
An vor Operationen wurde sie wegen Nosearculip operiert.
Sie haben keine Erkrankungen.
Ich werde diese Infos über die Erkrankung übernehmen.
Sie haben einen dröhnigen Konsum,
einen dröhnigen Konsum und einen Alkoholkonsum.
Sie haben keine Erkrankungen.
Sie haben eine Erkrankung.
Sie haben eine Hypertonie.
Sie hat keine Stress oder Probleme beim Arbeiten.
Aber sie haben ihre Interesse über ihre Hobbys verloren.
Sie, als Hobbys, könnte wir nennen, Lesern und Malen.
Und außer, dass sie ist vorlieg geimpft und im Sommer ist sie nach Holland gegangen und dort eine Bayern gehabt.
Wir haben eine Annästische Angaben am ehesten auf eine Depression und auf Reisdarm-Sendern.
Das ist ein bisschen interessant, aber.
Und auf.
Wie kommt es dir? Haben Sie den Pferdialdiagnosen?
Ja, ich habe nicht gesagt.
Haben Sie?
Der Verdachtdiagnose ist der Problem, außer dass es aus der Pferdialdiagnose ist.
Ich denke, Sie haben, es gibt viele meiner Freundin geschrieben.
Ich dachte, Reisdarm-Sendern und Scholiak kommen und auf.
Ja, das ist doch ganz gut. Warum sagen Sie Reisdarm-Syndrom?
Warum sagen Sie Depression?
Warum sagen Sie nicht erst die somatische Verdachtdiagnose?
Warum sagen Sie die psychische?
Warum? Wie kommen Sie dann drauf?
Warum? Weil sein, ich schuldige es sehr, Ihre Mutter hat eine Majodepression und sie, ich schuldige es.
Ja, aber nur weil mein Vater Herz empfagt hat, habe ich auch keinen Herz empfagt.
Ja, ich finde.
Also, das habe ich extra gesagt, damit Sie drauf denken.
Aber Sie müssen das somatische sagen.
Sie müssen, wie eben gesagt bei Ihrer Kollegin, Sie müssen das somatische,
eine somatische Verdachtdiagnose stellen, weil Sie haben hier gar keine Anzeichen einer psychischen Erkrankung.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe gesagt, ich möchte arbeiten, aber Sie schaffen es nicht.
Sie möchte malen, aber hat keine Kraft.
Aber Sie kommen wegen Bauchschmerzen.
Sie kommen in Ihre internistische Abteilung oder ich rufe, ich habe Bauchschmerzen, ich möchte wissen, was ich habe.
Sie will wissen, weil sie hat seit einem Jahr schon diese Beschwerden und sie kann nicht mehr.
Sie möchte deswegen, kommt sie am Sonntagmorgen um 12 Uhr oder 11 Uhr in die Ambulanz und sagt, ich habe Beschwerden, was mache ich jetzt?
Mein Haushalts, da war sie schon gewesen.
Der Haushalts hat nichts gefunden.
Er hat gesagt, du hast nichts, kannst arbeiten gehen oder ich schreibe dich krank, du hast aber nichts.
Er hat den Budapest genommen und Ultraschall gemacht, wenn ich.
Richtig?
Ja, genau.
Jetzt sagen Sie nochmal, Ihr Verdachtdiagnose nochmal.
Okay, als Verdachtdiagnose denke ich, sie hat es jetzt in Kolito, das ist ja.
Was noch?
Das ist.
Es könnte nicht ein Infektion sein, weil sie keine Fieber hat.
Es gibt bestimmte Patronisse, befunden, aber auf dem Stuhl.
Okay, jetzt haben Sie Patronisse, hat Diagnose gesagt, sagen Sie, sagen Sie sagen, Kolitis Ulzerosa, Morbis Kohn und sie haben gesagt, Sylvia Ki.
Ja, können Sie eigentlich davon ausschließen?
Ja, wir haben über Ihren Ernährungsstrationen gefragt und sie hat gesagt, keine Unverträchtigkeit oder ein bestimmter.
Ich sage aber, Kolitis Ulzerosa ist meistens mit, der Durchfall ist meistens mit Blut verbunden.
Einen Jahr schon, muss schon sein.
Okay, was würden Sie sagen, Kohn oder Sylvia Ki, was glauben Sie?
Ich würde sagen Sylvia Ki, weil die.
gibt es Atralgia aber, die Patientin hat gesagt.
Sie hat Atralgia im Gelenk, am Gelenken.
Sie hat gesagt, ich habe schon, aber stört mich nicht so sehr.
Muss nicht so ausgeprägt sein, richtig?
Mit Neurologisch-Symptome gibt es.
Neurologisch hat sie gesagt, ja, Stimmungsschwankungen, also Psychiogen,
das kann sein, aber man muss jetzt nicht unbedingt noch andere Sachen haben.
Man kann haben diese Sachen, aber man muss es nicht haben.
Also ich würde die Verdachtsiagnose zur Diakene nehmen,
weil es schon so lange dauert, immer wieder Durchfall,
Gewichtsverlust.
Patientin ist jung, 35 Jahre alt, ist eine Frau, ist auch öfters,
ja, und sie hat Gewichtsverlust und sie will geholfen werden.
Ja, also es geht nicht mehr und sie hat bisher keine Hilfe gefunden.
Würde ich jetzt so behaupten, was machen wir mit der Patientin?
Ja, ist das so, was machen wir?
So weiterer Abklärung würde ich die Patientin-Körperl untersuchen
und auf Vitalparameter und Vitalvertests messen.
Danach würde eine Blutabnahme durchführen.
Im Blutabnahme würde ich Entzündungparameter,
Neubelwerte, Nebelwerte und Routine-biokämmische Parameters messen,
veranlasen.
Also ich würde eine Chronoskopie veranlasen.
Was würden Sie Blut noch abnehmen?
Was kann man noch abnehmen, wenn Sie die Verdachtsiagnose zur Lacki haben?
Wir können einen Stuhl-Analysis beführen.
Blut, Blut habe ich gesagt.
Was würden Sie noch abnehmen?
Bestimmte Werte können Sie jetzt schon abnehmen.
Dann haben wir die in zwei Tagen und wissen, ob Sie eine Zölder-Ki haben oder nicht.
Leider, ich wusste nicht.
Ganz gut, Terminase.
Schon mal gehört?
Ja, ja, ich habe.
Ja, IgA kann man da messen.
Man kann natürlich auch Antikörper gegen Entomysium machen,
aber ganz gut, Terminase Antikörper sind eigentlich die wichtigsten aktuell.
Und dann kann man was machen?
Eine Chronoskopie oder eine Zölder-Ki?
Eine Magischspielung oder Chronoskopie, was besser?
Chronoskopie ist besser.
Warum?
Nach meiner Meinung.
Ja, aus der Verdachtsiagnose dachte ich, Chronoskopie ist besser.
Aber würden Sie auch Magenspielung machen?
Ich denke, das ist nicht benötig, aber ich weiß nicht, wie ich bin.
Keine Magenspiegelung, wenn Sie den Dünndarm beurteilen wollen wegen einer Zottenatrophie bei Zölder-Ki.
Sie sind kein Internist, oder?
Ja.
Sie sind ein paar Bereisen.
Ja, ich bin Laboraufschläger mit.
Okay.
Man kann eine Magenspiegelung machen, mit tiefe Magenspiegelung,
bis in den 12-Fingerdamm, Dünndamm rein,
zum Beispiel weiter, und kann dann Biopsy entnehmen aus dem Zotten.
Dünndamm-Biopsy.
Ja.
Schon mal gehört?
Dann kann man sehen, ob die Zotten sich verändert haben oder nicht,
ob es eine Atrophie gibt.
Das nennt man Zottenatrophie.
Was machen Sie als Therapie?
Gewebstranskultaminase.
Sie haben gesagt.
Gewebstranskultaminase, genau.
Ganzkultaminase 2, oder das Gesamt-IGA gibt es auch.
Okay.
Was machen wir als Therapie, Herr Ostensäu,
wenn die Patientin eine Zölder-Ki hat?
Was ist die Therapie?
Die Therapie passt ja also aus einer nördlichsten Zustand.
Wir müssen diesen Weiprotein-Inhalten-Produkten
Karenzen oder verboten.
Welche? Was für eine Karenze?
Weiprotein.
Noch mal.
Kultanfreie Dez.
Ja, genau.
War ein bisschen schwierig, ne?
Ja, es war schwierig für mich.
Ich habe mich nicht verstanden,
warum die Patientin eine Verdacht,
denken wir, Zölder-Ki hocan.
Warum nicht Morbus-Kron?
Kann man auch denken, klar.
Kann man auch denken, aber die Sache ist ja,
die Patientin hat das schon so lange.
Ja, und letztendlich muss man überlegen,
die hat erstens keine Blutbeimengung,
zum Beispiel muss aber nicht sein bei Morbus-Kron,
aber ist eine Alternative.
Vollkommen richtig.
Deswegen habe ich ja gesagt,
Chronoskopie und Magenspiegel.
Ja.
Das ist eine Alternative.
Deswegen habe ich ja gesagt,
Chronoskopie und Magenspiegel.
Eine Kollegin hat gefragt, Brot,
aber die Patientin hat gesagt, kein...
Ja, hat sie nicht bemerkt,
sie hat nicht darauf geachtet, hat sie gesagt.
Ich habe nicht aufgepasst.
Okay.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?